questa non l'ho scritta io però per un
riff molto utile a introdurre una strada
una strada da cui vorrei partire per
questa chiacchierata una strada
rivoluzionaria suo malgrado la bowery
una strada nella parte bassa di
manhattan
una strada che dal nome anche al
quartiere circostante che dagli anni
sessanta agli anni ottanta in realtà più
che rivoluzionari era un luogo
assolutamente di degrado in un luogo di
criminalità ha luogo la patria del
senzatetto degli alcolizzati degli
spacciatori aveva una caratteristica
positiva però era probabilmente in tutta
new york uno dei posti dove poter
trovare un alloggio al prezzo più basso
esattamente come una pensione e per
molti giovani che da tutto il mondo su
vivono un fascino di quella città era un
approdo quasi naturale lo fu anche per
il giovane lou reed in fuga dalla
rigidità per familiare può aver subito
ben due elettroshock a causa della sua
delle sue tendenze omosessuali
ecco trovò in qualche modo un rifugio in
quella terra di nessuno patria dei
diseredati che si stanno man mano
popolando di personalità creative
lo scrittore poeta visionario william
burroughs per esempio quasi a creare le
basi per quello che è successo dieci
anni dopo con un locale che e fuoco la
scena musicale di new york il 16 bis a
detta di thein a weymouth tra bassista
dei talking heads
l'unico locale le quali si poteva
suonare la musica che non passava nelle
radio in quel momento il sì visivi 16
bis sulla bowery diventò il covo per
un'esplosiva stagione rivoluzionaria che
ebbe il suo nome di punta in patti smith
dei talking heads e nei ramos non è che
traggono di diritto nella storia della
musica non fu solo musica la bowery fu
per esempio anche il primo terreno di
sperimentazione per keith haring il
primo street artists primo graffitista
della storia quando uno street art non
esisteva ancora in alcuni muri diroccati
della poveri lui potere
desidera i suoi primi esperimenti
togliendo le macerie alla spazzatura in
quella terra di nessuno trova un luogo
dove nessuno gli dava la caccia mentre
faceva queste queste opere la storia
della bowery finisce finisce con rudolph
giuliani con la sua tolleranza zero a
dare a ridare lustro e decoro a tutta
tutta manhattan a tutta una nathan e
fine anche per i principi della gente
efficacia non era diventata a quel punto
un quartiere chic le case potevano
essere anche affittate vendute attrezzi
a tariffe a tariffe più alte di recente
david byrne esprimendo un giudizio sulla
sua manhattan sulla luna lui ha cantate
da amato profondamente la paragona a un
quartiere di dubai
un uomo che sta perdendo completamente
la sua identità culturale e immagine
ipotizza anche di trasferirsi da qualche
altra parte
nei quartieri più ricchi di cultura
sempre a new york non deve stupire il
fatto che la realtà marginale dall età
di degrado scaturiscano delle scintille
di rivoluzione del resto la musica come
l'hardcore un hardcore punk e la cultura
che per prima incominciate a codificare
l'arte del 23 york self o per meglio
dire la cultura indipendente che si
oppone i meccanismi di mercato
nasce proprio in simultanea fransat
uniti e l'inghilterra nasce anche dal
degrado del quartiere addirittura arriva
a codificare un codice comportamentale
con la strada non si assumono alcolici
non si assumono droghe per contrastare
per certi versi certe derive umani
presenti quegli scenari ma forse la
rivoluzione più grande che viene da
queste terre di nessuno da queste da
questo grandissimo degrado suburbano e
li pop ovvero la musica che dà dignità a
persone a cittadini considerati dalla
civiltà dei consumi di serie b e di
serie c e diventa un network e diventa
una musica sgrammaticata che abolisce
completamente alla melodia e incomincia
a rappare messaggi e comincia a essere
anche danze cominciasse anche altre arte
figurativa e si propaga di periferia in
periferia di katyn ghetto fino ad
assumere le proporzioni anche ea
sfondare completamente i mercati cosa
che succede ancora ancora oggi anche
dalle nostre parti è successo qualche
cosa di simile
la generazione dei gruppi degli anni 90
che forse l'ultima generazione nata
fuori dalle logiche di mercato dalle
case discografiche ad avere una certa
popolarità alla sua incubatrice naturale
nella nella stagione delle occupazioni
nei centri autogestite nei centri
sociali una stagione anche di conflitto
per certi versi ma soprattutto una
stagione che genera dei luoghi dove si
possono fare degli esperimenti dove la
musica può crescere senza le tempistiche
dettate dal mercato dove si può
costruire quotidianamente mese dopo mese
anno dopo danno un contatto con un
pubblico che cresce ed è anche la scena
musicale che pone fine a un decennio di
essere figlia che ricomincia inserire
nei nuovi linguaggi
la parola e la canzone italiana quindi
salento abbiamo anche avuto delle
esperienze molto significative
a questo riguardo del resto anche la
canzone d'autore la canzone con cui noi
tutti quanti siamo cresciuti che è
diventata non solo più musica ma anche
cultura italiana nasce da una stagione
di antagonismo anche di conflitto le
canzoni di lucio dalla e de gregori di
fabrizio de andrè
nasco in una stagione una stagione molto
accesa di fortissime tensioni sociali e
culturali e questo mi fa pensare che
oggi gli scenari sono completamente
diversi delle città che è importante che
si vogliono definire importanti
dovrebbero avere a cuore la presenza di
luoghi non serve necessariamente il
conflitto non serve il degrado non serve
la devianza non sono le droghe anzi non
resiste generazione più pure pulita di
quella dei musicisti che hanno oggi
trent'anni
servono i luoghi servono i luoghi di
libertà servono i luoghi dove le tante
città possibili possono incontrarsi
la musica è capace di imprimere un
soffio di creatività ma non
necessariamente tutti dovranno diventare
cattivi anzi potranno essere non degli
artisti ma potranno essere creativi in
tutti i settori nei quali si ri
progetterà una società del futuro
e molto importante che questi spazi
vengano preservati qualcuno potrà anche
obiettare che chi se ne frega se i
rischi che escono nella cultura
underground saranno più o meno belli
chissenefrega della produzione
letteraria dell'arte contemporanea uno
potrebbe anche bastare ascoltare la
musica al 40 ascoltare la musica delle
44 canzoni 40 50 canzoni che ogni
stagione sono veicolati da tutti i
canali ufficiali potrebbe anche
semplicemente intrattenersi con la
musica dei talent che tanto potrebbe non
cambiare nulla
però se noi andiamo ad analizzare anche
solo le vita di una delle ultime grandi
popstar nella nostra epoca steve jobs ci
rendiamo conto che ad ogni passaggio
lui esprime un debito di riconoscenza
per le controculture che hanno
contrassegnato la zona di san francisco
la storia di quella di quell'area lui si
ritiene appartenente alla cultura hippy
e ritiene che queste radici gli abbiano
dato tutta la sua capacità di
trasformare
le sue visioni in grandi tattili
concretezza che tutto il mondo ha molto
ben presente non è solo steve jobs
l'area di san francisco che è stata la
patria di tantissime controcultura è al
centro di tutta una serie di aziende che
hanno stravolto completamente l'economia
mondiale
certo che noi italiani rimane anche un
po l'amaro in bocca perché federico
faggin un ricercatore italiano
beh è stato quello che per primo ha
inventato il microchip e touch screen
se il nord italia dell'epoca avesse
avuto più fantasia al potere fosse stato
forse meno provinciale ci fossero stati
forse più visionari pronti a raccogliere
ea intercettare l'enorme potenzialità re
con le scoperte forse avremmo avuto
molto tempo prima era la nostra silicon
valley forse saremmo anche un paese
diverso in questo momento in regia
nel mondo musicale che possiamo anche
usare come metafora per analizzare anche
molti altri mondi il 2000 si apre con
una grandissima promessa un album
l'album rivoluzionario dei radiohead che
arrivano a rivoluzionare anche le
proprie certezze acquisite stravolgono
completamente
la grammatica della musica e soprattutto
la grammatica della canzone si ha la
percezione di essere entrati nel 2000 e
che il 2000 sia veramente l'anno del
futuro come c'è un aspettavano è
un'illusione che dura quattro minuti 09
perché herat a quello che succederà
negli anni successivi sarà il vedere
scomparire progressivamente la musica
che fino a dieci anni prima che sarà
nelle stagioni degli anni novanta era
elemento centrale nella vita dei ragazzi
delle persone
era un fuoco sacro era una dimensione
attraverso la quale si cercava di
decifrare il mondo beh da si vedrà
perdere completamente di centralità di
significato fino ad apparire anche solo
sui quotidiani con un peso e un
importanza che si vedrà ritagliata fra
più o meno fra il sudoku l'astrologia e
[ __ ] lodge
io sono nato nei primi anni sessanta e
ho vissuto soprattutto allo spettatore
tutte le rivoluzioni musicali mi sono
reso conto che la musica anzi se noi
pensiamo a tutte le evoluzioni culturali
la prima cosa che ci viene in mente una
band una canzone un taglio di capelli
un abito che viene fuori dalla musica
successivamente pensiamo ai fatti
storici e personalità politiche o del
mondo scientifico
questa cosa mi è sempre stata molto
chiara è sempre stato molto chiaro che
c'è stato un prima e un dopo prima
lavorare nel mondo della musica non solo
coi musicisti fotografare la musica
parlare della musica in radio perché non
commercializzare la musica significava
avere la sensazione di avere un peso nel
proprio tempo
significava prendere parte a qualche
cosa di importante
oggi io che vivono il mondo della musica
mi rendo conto che tutto diventato
estremamente meccanico e le persone che
producono la musica fattivamente sono
persone che non si appassionano alla
musica che trattano gli uffici stampa
che parlano della musica scrivono cose
delle quali non crede
la maggior parte delle persone che
trasmette in musica in radio trasmette
in musica la quale non si appassiona
profondamente e devo dire che anche i
musicisti incominciano anzi ho mai
cominciato da almeno 10 anni ad avere un
atteggiamento molto disincantata e molto
disilluso quasi che percorrono un
processo lineare fra chi ha l'esigenza
di ascoltare la musica la musica di
sinistra umana per chi la suona
la scrive e chi l'ascolta sia ormai
un'utopia
certo che i professionisti della musica
ci diranno beh internet ha rovinato
tutto
non ci sono più le vendite non ci sono
più i numeri per forza la musica sia
ridotta io ho assistito però ad alcuni
episodi che vorrei mettere in relazione
per dare una lettura leggermente diversa
mentre
negli anni verso la fine degli anni 90
uno dei presidenti della filiale
italiana più grandi multinazionali
sentenziava in modo tale sant su
internet
parlandone come di un passatempo per
ragazzi di cui fra sei mesi non
sentiremo più parlare
la vera tecnologia che affascina
avedisco gladius profes all'epoca si
chiamava radio control un meccanismo
diabolico che permetteva di stilare
classifiche in base ai passaggi
radiofonico sulla fl improvvisamente il
radio controllo di vento il parametro
attraverso il quale giudicare la musica
i musicisti indipendentemente dalla
propria storia dalle proprie della
qualità del proprio messaggio e tutti
quanti noi
finimmo per essere incastrati questo
meccanismo ma non fa l'unica diavoleria
tecnologica ce ne fu un'altra ci fu un
software ha presentato un software in
grado di riconoscere canzoni di sicuro
successo
neanche philip dick neanche gli
sceneggiatori di terminator mai osato
qualcosa di tanto fanta catastrofica
successivamente in un convegno
internazionale viene presentata l'idea
rivoluzionaria di indicare musicisti la
scrittura di ritornelli semplici
facilmente trascrivibili in suonerie per
telefoni cellulari
la cosa si era in borsa delle
multinazionali fece l'ultimo passaggio
ovvero i tempi di investimento della
musica fra l'investimento e la resa
dovete diventare talmente stretti da non
permettere neanche più di investire su
qualche cosa che poteva nascere e avere
una sua fisiologia ed essere trasmesso
le tempistiche umane e naturali
occorreva investire su artistiche
somigliassero artistica non appena avuto
successo e di qui fino al tritacarne dei
talent fino a quello che praticamente
sono le previsioni perché saranno le
previsioni per i prossimi anni
scomparirà il cd l'industria
discografica sarà nelle mani delle
grandi compagnie telefoniche vivendo
conto che mio tempo è finito
santo subito alle conclusioni
io credo che oggi più che mai abbiamo
bisogno della musica perché la musica
come dicevo prima infonda creatività la
musica capace di non lasciare fuori
nessuno di mettere connessioni mondi
credibilità idee di tale slancio e
coraggio ai sogni anche l'ingenuità
voterà materia prima verso la quale si
possono realizzare i sogni
purtroppo oggi come dicevo prima 40
canzoni in una stagione occupano tutti
gli spazi possibili la musica c'è la
musica che fanno i ragazzi tra i venti
trentenni in questo momento è una musica
è veramente molto sana e capace di dare
quello di cui abbiamo bisogno
si tratta solo semplicemente di essere
più attenti e di esigere che siano delle
trasmissioni di fra chi la fa e chi la
ascolta la musica più lineare si tratta
semplicemente di essere più umani perché
in questo momento essere umani vuol dire
essere rivoluzionari e sentirsi
rivoluzionari o sintomo
incontrovertibile del fatto di essere
quanto mai umani grazie